Delta debugging can be used to simplify other domains rather than just input.
For instance, it can be used to simplify changes. Let me illustrate this.
For instance, it can also be used to simplify changes to your code.
When would such a thing be needed? Well, simple situation.
This is you and this is your major web hosting service
The building or infrastructure and lots and lots of third party open-source libraries
and since you want to keep your service up-to-date
with respect to security patches and everything, you have to update these libraries on regular intervals
So you're getting patches that is large changes to a code base on regular intervals.
This is the same as upgrading the libraries to the newest version
and the changes between versions that is the patches, can easily contain 10,000s of source lines.
Here comes in new patch, patch 3 also with 10,000 source code lines.
All of a sudden, your infrastructure fails after applying the patch. What is the cause of the error.
This is an instance of a problem that's more generally called,
yesterday, my program worked, today it does not--why?
Changed something--as a result of the change, something no longer works
and you want to figure out what is it in that change that makes the program go wrong?
Again, we can use delta debugging to simplify this.
Assume the patch that causes the failure can be broken down into several subpatches.
For instance, these 10,000 of changed lines would be different locations of the program
and each of these locations that means a separate place to patch or a different subpatch.
The idea would now be that maybe a subset of these subpatches
would already suffice to create the error.
In other words, we would simplify the patch to find a minimal subset of the patch that creates the failure.